bonjour et bienvenue pour cette science
aujourd'hui consacré à l'organe sans
lequel cette option n'existerait pas le
cerveau en tant que centre nerveux à
l'origine de notre personnalité de notre
comportement et de notre intelligence
le cerveau est un peu à l'homme ce que
l'assise yvette under ou encore la
carapace à la tortue c'est la clé de
notre survie
il ne le savez certainement pas mais le
premier hominidé qui a eu un jour l'idée
de jeter une pièce sur ses congénères
plutôt que de les affronter à mains nues
vanité en fait de poser la première
pierre de l'évolution du genre humain
c'est beau ce que tu vis à vis dans hull
c'est merci mais ne nous y trompons pas
l'homme n'a pas non plus démarrer de
zéro pour ce qui est de l'intelligence
bien avant de donner naissance à l'homme
les primates étaient déjà les mammifères
les plus ancefa lisez et certainement
les plus intelligents mais au fait est
ce qu'un cerveau plus gros signifie
vraiment être plus intelligent non parce
que les oiseaux sont très réputés pour
leur crâne de piaf alors que les
perroquets et quand vous disposez une
intelligence certaine ils peuvent même
communiquer avec l'homme et se
reconnaître dans des miroirs et que dire
des invertébrés comme les poulpes et les
fourmis
du haut de leurs minuscules ganglion
nerveux qu'on appelle d'ailleurs à
appeler un cerveau les premiers sont
capables de résoudre des problèmes
complexes alors que les second vivent
dans des sociétés dont la parfaite
organisation laisse songeur alors
pourquoi un gros cerveau serait t'il
mieux qu'un petit pour être intelligent
du point de vue strictement théorique
selon le principe dit de la masse
propres à plus petit cerveau devrait
disposer de moins de place et donc
comporter moins de tissu cérébral -
tissu cérébral serait égal à moins
d'intelligence
ça c'est la théorie et comme toute
théorie elles s'appuient sur des
hypothèses
la première de ces hypothèses étant que
la taille des cellules cérébrales les
neurones les astrocytes et c'est yves
liane est la même pour toutes les
espèces
la deuxième est temps que les replis du
néocortex qui en augmente
considérablement la surface dans un
volume égal ne jouent pas de rôle
significatif dans le fonctionnement du
cerveau et la troisième que le connecte
hommes c'est à dire que l'ensemble du
réseau des connexions des cellules
cérébrales entre elle ne varie pas entre
les espèces
et ne joue pas non plus de rôle
significatif dans le fonctionnement du
cerveau dis donc ça fait quand même
beaucoup de trucs à négliger tout ça là
pour que ce soit vrai quand même parce
que bon l appel à pas l'air de casser
des noix cette théorie un sur le papier
c'est sûr qu'elle al'air fumeuse mais
dans la pratique elle se défend pas mal
tu regardes l'oeil par exemple l'oeil a
la même origine embryologie que le
cerveau chez un animal nigon comme chez
l'homme par exemple sa taille est normal
mais chez un animal nocturne comme le
tard si alors là il est hypertrophié ce
qui lui permet de capter plus de lumière
al'inverse l'oreille interne qui comme
l'oeil est d'origine cérébrale montre
une atrophie des canots semi circulaire
chez les cétacés art ces structures ici
clore hier john servent normalement à
capter les mouvements de la tête par
rapport au corps mais comme les dauphins
et les baleines n'ont plus de cauet ne
peuvent le bouger la tête du cou et bien
les canots semi circulaire ne servent
plus à rien enfin plus généralement il
est indéniable que les espèces de
mammifères qui ont le servent le plus
gros sont les plus intelligentes
les éléphants les primates et les
cétacés sont les trois groupes de
mammifères chez qui le cerveau est le
plus gros et il n'y a que chez eux que
l'on rencontre dessine d'intelligence
tels que la vie en société la capacité à
fabriquer des objets en réponse à des
besoins ne pouvons être résolu
immédiatement ou encore la
reconnaissance dans un miroir qui dénote
une certaine forme de conscience de soi
et même une certaine conscience de la
mort comme chez les éléphants qui savent
reconnaître les ossements de leurs
congénères et qui les rassemble
soigneusement donc il ya quand même une
assez bonne corrélation entre
intelligence et a glissé au moins chez
les mammifères
oui enfin la taille du cerveau c'est
quand même pas tout preneur exemple des
éléphants nains une espèce d'éléphants
est un très récemment qu'ils vivaient en
sicile il y à quelques milliers d'années
à peine cet éléphant avait un cerveau de
2 kg environ soit un peu plus gros que
le cerveau d'un être humain moyen qui
fait normalement à kg 4 avec son cerveau
de 2 kg pour un poids de 150 kilos ce
petit pêche il y en avait un rapport
entre masse cérébrale et poids du corps
incroyablement proche du nôtre
rendez vous compte chez un éléphant
actuelle le cerveau fait 5 kg ces
quelques kilos de plus oui mais par
rapport au reste qui fait plus de 5
tonnes
si la taille du cerveau étaient tous qui
importe alors ce petit éléphant aurait
dû être extrêmement intelligent plus que
ses proches parents vivant et au moins
autant que nous mais les profs
paléontologique sont formels ses
éléphants se comportaient belgian comme
des éléphants et rien d'autre donc avoir
un gros cerveau c'est bien joli mais ce
n'est pas tout n'en déplaise à ceux
qu'ils croient bon maintenant ça va bien
un coup ça marche un autre ça marche pas
puis ça marche en théorie puis ça marche
plus vu ça marche et les mammifères et
puis ça marche plus si bien que ça
finalement
y'en a ras-le-bol s'y associer à la
taille du cerveau à l'intelligence ne
fonctionne pas aussi bien que cela
devrait alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on
continue
le faire la réponse est très simple
c'est juste la chose la plus simple à
étudier et aussi c'est la seule donnée à
propos du cerveau qui peut fossilisés et
oui le moulage de la boîte crânienne
qu'on appelle moulage endocrinien est
très facile à faire à partir d'un crâne
et il se préserve naturellement dans le
registre fossile ce type à boulsa par
contre la boîte crânienne ce n'est pas
le cerveau du coup même si on conserve
une bonne idée de la taille
approximative du cerveau en étudiant le
moulage endocriniens on perd les
informations concernant sa morphologie
et les fichiers qu'ils recouvrent ainsi
que toutes les informations sur l'aspect
la physiologie du tissu cérébral et sur
le connector ceci étant mise au point
que nous apprend l'étude des moulages
endocriniens des hominidés fossiles sur
l'évolution de notre cerveau en premier
lieu aussi vous croyez qu'on ne savait
rien à ce propos et bien détrompez vous
les paléontologues possède une masse de
données considérables concernant
l'évolution de la taille de l'endocrâne
chez les hominidés fossiles mais
décortiquons tout cela ensemble alors
tout commence avec toumaï et les
australopithèques c'est-à-dire lucie et
ses comparses
bien que déjà tout à fait bipèdes la
taille de laurent de crâne est à peu
près la même que chez les chimpanzés
soit 400 à 500 centimètres cubes
on notera donc que le volume du cerveau
et la bipédie n'ont pas évolué de
concert et qu'entre 10 millions d'années
et deux millions d'années la taille du
cerveau n'a pas beaucoup bougé chez les
hominidés
les choses s'accélèrent chez le genre
homo à l'époque des derniers
d'australopithèques apparaît le premier
représentant du genre homo homo habilis
qui avait un cerveau à peine plus grand
que ses prédécesseurs 600 centimètres
cubes environ
là où les choses vont vraiment changé
c'est chez homo erectus la la taille du
cerveau va être presque multiplié par
deux et elle augmentera encore de 50%
pour atteindre 1500 et 1400 centimètre
cube en moyenne chez l'homme de
néandertal est chez nous respectivement
dernier représentant apparu de cette
histoire mais n'allez surtout pas vous
imaginer que nous sommes le point
culminant de cette évolution car
certains homos erectus en afrique ou
encore en asie comme l'homme de pékin
par exemple au tata de façon
complètement indépendante détail de
cerveau qui n'ont rien à envier à la
nôtre en fait
a tendance à l'augmentation de la taille
du cerveau n'est pas un phénomène unique
elle a eu lieu plusieurs fois dans de
nombreuses signé d'hommes il y a d'abord
eu deux lignes et d'homo erectus l'une
africaine et l'autre asiatique dont nous
venons de parler mais il ya aussi
l'homme de néanderthal et l'homme
moderne tous les deux descendants de
deux autres populations différentes de
mme rictus et le développement parallèle
de deux cultures très différentes chez
ces deux espèces rend bien compte de
celle du cerveau comme en témoigne la
pratique des arts et des rites
funéraires chez l'homme de néandertal et
chez l'homme moderne mais pas chez homo
erectus ou quoi qu'il en soit les
données montrent des ramifications lors
de l'évolution de la taille du cerveau
qui n'ont rien à voir avec la vision
simpliste linéaire est pourtant
omniprésente d'une tendance à
l'augmentation dans notre seule ligne et
cette vision simpliste est d'autant plus
fort ce que récemment ont été découverts
en géorgie sac crâne appartenant
justement à homo erectus et montrant que
chez cette espèce d'homme la taille du
cerveau pouvait énormément varier d'un
individu à l'autre aussi bien vers
d'aigreur de taille qu'elle est toute
petite
mais si vous persistez vraiment à
vouloir croire que l'évolution du
cerveau a été un long fleuve tranquille
et sans âme ification nous avons
peut-être la solution il suffit de
prendre la taille moyenne du cerveau de
chaque espèce est alors c'est le mimi
c'est le rara c'est le miracle
notre belle ligne droite ans convoité
apparaît
m
matin
ouais minutes avions tu oublie un peu de
nous parler de l'homme de florès le
fameux guide des paléontologues avec son
cerveau d'à peine 3 180 centimètres cube
même rapporter à son poids plume censé
avoir été de la taille de celui d'un
chimpanzé ou d'un australopithèque et il
aurait vécu entre moins cent mille et
moins dix mille ans à la même époque que
l'homme moderne et l'homme de néandertal
l'homme de florès nous démontre donc que
le volume du cerveau n'a pas fait
qu'augmenter chez l'homme il s'est
diversifié
c'est exactement ce qui s'est aussi
produit chez les autos cette partie de
très peu de diversité en termes de
taille de cerveau il ya 40 millions
d'années leur ses avoirs a grandi chez
les dauphins alors qu'il est devenu
proportionnellement plus petit chez le
cachalot
à tel point que ces derniers possèdent
un cerveau proportionnellement aussi
petit que celui des plus anciens c'est
assez connu les harkis recettes
bon alors finalement si on prend
l'évolution des techniques comme
témoignage direct de l'intelligence des
hominidés et qu'on la compare à
l'évolution du cerveau est ce que
finalement on constate une corrélation à
première vue la réponse est oui
l'apparition des galets aménagé coïncide
à peu près avec celle des premières
espèces du genre homo c'est à dire des
hominidés dans le volume encéphalique
moyen dépasse celui d'un chimpanzé
c'est peut-être aussi à cette même
époque qu'a dû se développer l'ère de
broca une petite région du cortex à
l'origine de la coordination motrice
nécessaires à la fabrication d'outils
mais aussi et surtout à la parole la
fabrication d'outils est un artisanat
qui nécessite une transmission au moins
oral du savoir il semble donc
raisonnable de penser que la fabrication
d'outils et la parole soit apparu en
même temps et écourt évoluer chez le
genre homo
ce qui est d'autant plus probable que
ces deux fonctions sont présidées par la
même région du cerveau et au fur et à
mesure que la taille du cerveau augmente
apparaissent les premiers bifaces puis
la domestication du feu et enfin que
l'homme au dernier néandertal
apparaîssait times moustérienne les
peintures rupestres et j'en passe
donc cette fois c'est sûr la taille du
cerveau et l'intelligence sont bel et
bien lié à red hat a attention n'a pas
trop vite nous parlons ici
d'intelligence en nous basant sur le
progrès technologique mais la vitesse à
laquelle ce type de progrès a eu lieu
ces 50 dernières années sans pour autant
qu'il soit lié à une modification de la
taille du cerveau nous montre qu'il faut
rester prudent et d'ailleurs rappelez
vous de notre homme de flores malgré son
petit cerveau les
les oncologues et les archéologues ont
découvert associés à des tas de pierres
finement taillée ainsi qu'à des foyers
de feu le hobbit maîtrisez donc le feu
et les mêmes techniques de taille que
ses contemporains au cerveau
hypertrophié plutôt pas mal pour une
espèce dans le cerveau était pourtant de
la même taille que celui d'un chimpanzé
et de ses lointains cousins les
australopithèques et to buy
en conclusion l'évolution de la taille
du cerveau chez l'homme ne se résume pas
à cette vision simpliste et linéaire
d'une longue et lente augmentation de sa
taille au fil du temps et des espèces la
taille du cerveau a augmenté de façon
convergente chez de nombreuses lignes et
d'hommes en particulier d'homo erectus
et a même diminué chez l'homme de florès
il n'y a donc pas de direction
privilégiée dans l'évolution de la
taille du cerveau
elle augmente ou diminue selon les
circonstances selon que la sélection
naturelle favorise l'une ou l'autre
tendance dans des circonstances précises
le cas de l'homme de florès n'en
déplaise à certains montrent que
l'évolution de l'homme et de son cerveau
ne peut pas se résumer à une simple
ligne droite
l aiguille sonnantes se diversifie et de
ce fait est imprévisible
le fait que ce soit nous qui
représentons à la dernière espèce
humaine vivante est un concours de
circonstances et sachant toutes les
voies évolutif qu'ont pu arpenter nos
cousins dans le passé tenté de prédire
l'évolution future de notre cerveau est
un exercice plus complexe qu'il n'y
paraît et c'est sans compter le fait que
le cerveau ne sert pas qu'à la
commission s'est aussi l'organe qui
coordonne vos mouvements inconscients
qui vous aide à vous réchauffer et qui
contrôle la sécrétion d'une très grande
quantité d'hormones y compris les
hormones de croissance et sexuelle
du coup le limiter à son seul usage dans
l'intellect est un peu dévalorisant et
finalement à l'ère de la miniaturisation
de l'informatique ou devenir plus petits
signifie devenir toujours plus
performants prétendre être le plus
intelligent parce qu'on a le plus gros
cerveau ne serait-il pas un petit peu
dépassé
pour ne pas dire primitif